ciao ragazzi bentornate una nuova
puntata nella cucina buttata me l'avete
chiesto in tanti di far tornare questo
ospite ecco perché sono lieto di riavere
all'interno di questo canale
lei si sente di gianluigi ma ciao
ragazzi ho un piacere essere di nuovo
qui possa avere un maglione a collo alto
per favore mi va bene anche un 40 gradi
all'ombra
scherzi a parte già oggi oggi che giorno
oggi è una domenica e domenica del mese
di agosto l'estate non avete bisogno
anche voi di questa ricetta
io sinceramente simile venduta che cosa
debba fare oggi oggi faremo il mio primo
di mare preferito in assoluto posso
andare un ristorante di pesce guardare
tutto il menu e 90 per cento delle volte
prenderò sempre gli spaghetti alle
vongole e per quanto io ne sappia
gianluigi è un maestro nel fare gli
spaghetti alle vongole bisogna dirlo
cioè se seguita su licenza farete un
figurone quindi bando alle ciance già to
try to gli onori di casa ok andiamo a
preparare degli ingredienti per fare gli
spaghetti alle vongole avremo bisogno di
prezzemolo fresco peperoncino piccante
qualche spicchio di pasta lunga olio
extra vergine di oliva vino
come piace a me ti passano le boccole
quelle termali può finalmente allora
doppia di qui vediamo questo che
dobbiamo cucinare forza è tutto
avrete qua pronti o acqua nel pentolone
procedimenti come facciamo con le
bombole vanno sporcate quindi si mettono
in acqua salata il ph deve essere come
quello del mare quindi andate a vedere
per ogni litro di acqua quanti
cucchiaini di sale ci vanno perché se ne
mettete di più con e mettete di meno la
vongola more delle vecchie dario
vestirsi e spicchi due ben un ora non si
può dire una volta finito andiamo sul
tagliere è a una una la prendiamo la
battiamo per vedere se ci lascia la
ricetta di sabbia se ci lascia la sabbia
la dobbiamo eliminare buono che cosa
devo fare queste tutto il canale nelle
tabelle di dama se ce ne hanno forza
forza animi comunali mo nel frattempo io
proseguo qui è un'altra cosa
se avete vongole con guscio rotto le
prendete le buttate via senza pietà
questo una vongola marcia vi rovina
tutto il piatto olio in padella quanto
cubi dobbiamo fare un leggero soffritto
nel frattempo io ti preparo i cambi di
prezzemolo faccia dell'olio non ce n'è
tanto siamo in cinque oggi votiamo mezzo
chilo adesso che dobbiamo fare mi sento
antonella clerici e adesso dobbiamo fare
adesso prendiamo i cambi di prezzemolo
che li mettiamo all'interno del nostro
soffitto i gambi gambi dagli una leggera
provincia ta per far uscire i loro aromi
e balli padella cosa avevo due
peperoncini smi non sa tutto non ti
toccare poi gli occhi volevamo una cosa
magari può dar fastidio la sfumate col
vino perché non gli piace il sapore del
vino può usare un bicchiere d'acqua
vengono ancora più leggere a me
onestamente la sfumata di vino piace
cosa facciamo come ci pare
forse non avete capito cucina puntata
non è solamente un programma di cucina
ma è soprattutto programma di filosofia
di vita
mammamia bravissimo avevamo la stessa
connessione mentale fare veramente un
plauso a guglielmo perché ha inclinato
la padella e l'olio tramite
perfettamente i suoi profumi gli aromi
di tutte le cose inserite all'interno
brasiliano chiediamo a questo punto i
gambi del prezzemolo e non ci interessa
più tenerli andiamo direttamente con le
vongole padella meno qui e di gelato
giammarco perché ha preso corso vino
ragazzi scadentissimo se avete un buon
vino in bottiglia utilizzatelo è
preferibile utilizzare un vino buono per
sfumare perché ce lo ritroviamo poi nel
piatto coprono tagli in un attimo
evaporare i fumi dell'alcol e poi
torniamo per due minuti come ve ne
accorgete se l'alcol è evaporato dal
vino a naso se non mi punge più il naso
potete tranquillamente andare oltre
andiamo a salare l'acqua poco di sale
dentro all'acqua perché tutta la
sapidità sane i nostri molluschi quindi
prima regola non salare il condimento
seconda regola mettere meno sale dentro
al bollitore andiamo a controllare
adesso se le nostre mongole si sono
aperte 20 secondi e via c'è un buco allo
stomaco di quelli proprio io pure sto
morendo di fame calcola 0 è arrivato il
momento di spegnere la fiamma tirare
fuori la padella e andare a sgusciare
tutte le nostre bombole non la lasciano
un pochino per decorazione a me lasciamo
qualcuna si parte proprio del guarda
così io faccio il resto
andiamo a travasare tutto il sughetto
lasciando l'ultima parte perché magari
può essersi depositata un po di sabbia
come potete vedere lascia un altro poco
pulisco la padella è arrivato in cottura
deve essere comune col succo della
padella la pasta sta andando quanto
manca mancano 34 minuti adesso
travasiamo la pasta dentro la nostra
padella in modo tale che la gdo cominci
a creare quella cretina
mi raccomando non aggiungete burri
panero le varie piccola smossa prima
volta che andiamo ad aggiungere un po di
acqua di cottura
voglio vedere il santo il salto il saldo
il santo
ma io faccio io
[Applauso]
ragazzi fiamma aspetta andiamo a mettere
prezzemolo a crudo e un bel giro d'olio
a crudo saltino e andiamo dirette a
tavola se non si sa dovete fare questo
movimento ragazzi ci siamo impiantiamo
assieme all'assaggio look professionale
perché lo spaghetto alle vongole il mio
cavallo di battaglia quindi chi è
vediamo quanto dettato bravo che bello
sapere che ogni tanto con cucina
guglielmo partiamo con le valutazioni
che dire ragazzi aspetto visivo
non so chi l'abbia fatta molto bella
allora si presenta benissimo forse avrei
messo un pochino più di prezzemolo a
finir bello il mio piatto non bellissimo
e non perché sto rosicando ma perché è
negato a chi a dario così sarei keepon
ammazzavampiri molto invitante il mio
piatto devo dire che anche piazzato beh
la giusta dose di gusci vuole che
cospargono un po acquista una superficie
ogni cosa sembra al posto giusto
otto e mezzo 8 e da otto e mezzo tutta
la vita a otto e mezzo 9 le do un sette
e mezzo ma l'abbiamo anche impiantata di
gran fretta ed ore
mamma mia ragazzi odori di mare imbucati
mare se chiudo gli occhi i ragazzi
sentono veramente il suono delle onde
sulla spiaggia come come
allora il 9 e mezzo all 88 e mezzo 99 in
mezzo faccio un appello a tutti i casi
non ha affatto un profumo che si chiama
tombola sono pronte a cospargere me
ovunque ho sentito che c'è il
peperoncino ma questa la mangerei anche
se dentro ci fosse il vetriolo
partiamo con la storia boccone
considerevole abbiamo
paolo safa o lo sa dipende anche molto
dalle bombole a devo dire un plauso va
fatta gianmarco che ha preso una vongola
strepitosa buonissima buon buona buona
bravo giallo c'è una nota di cantina che
spero non demolisca il palato di la
linea a dare lo sei bravissima gol anche
bravissimo e anche clamorosa poi sono un
amante del pesce come mio fratello
d'altronde hk a con mio sommo rammarico
devo dire che mi fa concorrenza ed è un
no detti e nissimo 98 e mezzo nove e
mezzo mondo il 10 perché sono un
bastardo ed è difficile dare 10 10 meno
che vedeva spesso al ristorante l'altro
molto deludente questa pazzesca per
questa razza risposto a pagare 12 14 13
euro mi accodo a gianluigi 13 euro
devo dire 14 euro immediatamente a 15
euro io dico a fa comunque ragazzi siamo
grati di questo video spero che vi sia
piaciuto mettete un like qua sotto se
vorreste vedere altre ricette di
gianluigi sappiamo che mi piace molto
quando lo mettiamo in cucina sia perché
è bello e sia perché è bello perché è
molto bravo fateci sapere quatto come
sempre cosa state facendo come state
lasciando il vostro posto vi state
divertendo siete riusciti a prendervi
delle ferie è stata ancora lavorando
oppure le vostre ferie sono appena
finite
noi saremo contenti di leggervi sotto
l'ombrellone si spera vi mando un bacio
grande a giovedì ciao
se manco un saluto di selezione
l'annunciato con la polizia
mi hanno finisco qui perché gli stronzi
mai fatto prima di me e stavano
mangiando mentre io stavo a riprendere è
ora riguarda le pare